este es el material que necesitarás para
construir tu robot es pau de soldadura
sin plomo la usarás para hacer
conexiones entre metales conduce
electricidad así que mantendrá el
circuito unido silicón caliente aquí
tenemos una barra de silicon que
usaremos para mantener unidas las partes
que no necesitan conducir electricidad
aquí tenemos dos resistor es estos son
dos resistor es de 41 años puedes
utilizar resistor es desde 40 a 200
somos todo depende de qué tan brillantes
quieres tus dulces leds o de qué tipo de
luces led escojas aquí tenemos nuestras
luces leds que son de color azul claro y
también necesitaremos cuatro clips estos
son dos motores de 1.5 a 3 volts y
funcionan muy bien con nuestras baterías
que son baterías doble a de 1.5 votos
cada una que juntas en serie
son tres volts también tenemos dos tapas
de botella que son de botella de agua
y tenemos algunos tubos termo
retráctiles los cuales vienen en muchos
tamaños y colores nosotros elegimos de
un dieciseisavo y un octavo de pulgada
también tenemos interruptores
deslizantes son interruptores de un polo
y doble tiro ajá pero le doblamos uno de
los tiros lo quitamos del camino y ahora
sólo son interruptores de un polo y un
tiro los usaremos como interruptores de
encendido y apagado y también tenemos
dos interruptores de un polo y doble
tiro con palanca de los cuales usaremos
un polo y ambos tiros y también tenemos
cables tenemos cable aislado de calibre
22 y de este cable tenemos varios
colores escogimos verde azul rojo
amarillo y blanco y los elegimos así
porque nos ayudará en los vídeos
podremos hacer distinguir mejor entre
los colores a la hora de estar sobre la
caja de baterías y esta es la caja de
baterías para pila doble y bueno estas
son las partes que necesitarás para
construir tu robot export en el
siguiente vídeo hablaremos de la
herramienta